what's about the new documentary obvi
this is a true story about the horrific
events that occurred in Paris Paris
November 2015 and and for those of you
just just take people back to the events
yeah and what it is you wanted to sort
of accomplish with yeah so on that
evening there were a series of sort of
coordinated attacks across Paris at
various different locations and and the
one that was the the most discussed
almost that definitely had the most loss
of life was a concert that was held at a
place called Tabata claun and the band
the Eagles of Death Metal were playing
at that venue in 89 people lost their
lives and it was you know along with all
of the other events that night was
really really sad and tragic and I am
very good friends with with the guys in
the band and they had actually been
doing a bunch of stuff with me for the
tower documentary when we were finishing
that up and then November happened and a
few months afterwards luckily you know
the band was able to make it out of
there but they went back to Paris last
February to finish their concert to
finish their show and we sort of decided
kind of last minute
that maybe it would be a good thing to
go and sort of document them going back
and not really for any other reason than
then to show the the band and their fans
collectively coming together and trying
to make something positive out of a
really horrible situation the it's
interesting because it the documentary
as they often do you start out with
maybe one in ten or even not knowing
what your intent is and then that can
change when a filmmaker makes a
conventional film they know what their
story is a documentary filmmaker has to
find the story as they're going what was
the story you found you obviously that
was your intention but what did you find
well we yeah we we knew that was gonna
we knew we were gonna focus on the
return concert we knew we were obviously
going to talk about the the events of
the bodycon but we didn't really know
what how to start the film off and
knowing jesse hughes the lead singer
in Joshua Homme you or the two founding
members knowing them as well as I do I
sort of instinctually knew about their
relationship they've got one of the best
relationships I've ever seen I mean they
really are in fact there was someone who
saw the movie last week and they said
that they feel they've watched the first
love story of 2017 by seeing these two
guys because they really have a genuine
deep bond for each other and have always
been there for each other and it really
started normally when I started
interviewing someone for a talk I'll
I'll ask them questions just to get them
comfortable on camera and get them
talking so I would just ask them like
how'd you two meet and there they are
two sharp-witted very funny very
likeable guys that have a deep bond and
about halfway through that first
interview my producing partner who is my
best friend who I grew up with he came
up to me says oh I see what you're doing
here these are like the two main
characters that we're gonna follow and
it ended up being a happy accident and
it ended up being a great way to set her
set up the film because you know Jessie
and Josh are so close but Joshua doesn't
really tour with the group right so he
wasn't there the night of the attacks
and so you have these two best friends
that are literally an ocean apart on the
worst night of their lives and and it's
about how one was able to be there for
you know for the other and vice versa
during this really difficult time it's
it's a really sweet a loving film that
I'm very proud of and I'm just really
honored that my friends were able to to
let me help them in any way I could
you